with life getting more demanding and
hectic all the time it seems there's
only one way to cope multitasking gurus
and life hackers make a living telling
us how to get better at it but can we
actually multitask some psychologists
model visual attention as being like a
spotlight it can only be shown in One
Direction at any one time even though
we're constantly receiving a huge amount
of information from our senses it's only
possible for a small amount to make it
through to conscious awareness you can
see this very clearly in the famous
Invisible Gorilla experiment when NASA
concentrates exclusively on how often
basketball players in whites pass the
ball most people completely miss the
gorilla walking across the screen and
beating his chest
so multitasking makes us at best
inefficient and at worst downright
dangerous if you're feeling like you
should be doing 17 things at once
remember that's just not the way your
brain is wired
[Music]